yoru is one of valeran's worst agents
they've also got the denial of the push
back in the nano swarm gonna hold them
back even further and this map is
looking done well vikings have got to go
back to the drawing board on that we've
seen the first yoru come out here in
masters and maybe the last based on how
it uh how it played out there are teams
that tried to make your work but nobody
ever succeeded with him
oh what the how did i not see him but
there was one team who saw yoru's true
potential and one player who managed to
do the impossible the old's out of
forsaken confirming exactly where he is
he hears the steps the flash is hell oh
meadow gets away with the first forsaken
has to take him down and he does a
fourth kill for this man not even
blinded up that operator now ready to
take them down the shots miss though a
lifeline perhaps and they've caught him
on the way out the flash is perfect
the decoy was popped and they shot it
they know that they're coming forsaken
with another kill and bangkai tucked in
the corner how does forsaken get away
with that he was so low and a third is
bound as well that's utterly
unreasonable
confirming the players are still in here
mine freaks picked up another this is
starting to look like it's done how has
a vulva gotten away with that but the
answer is immediate meadow the last man
standings taken down and aipac have done
it
all right folks before we get in the
video i want to ask you to please sub to
the channel and turn on notifications if
you haven't done it yet because it
really does help okay so if you know
anything about valrant you know that
yoru has been one of the worst
characters in the game since he came out
everyone agreed yoru looked cool but
when it came to actually winning games
nobody really ever figured out how to
get the most out of his kit this team
that duo specifically always has the
most percentage of their team skills
oh my goodness he read them like a book
compared to every other duelist yoru
always seemed underwhelming even now
months after getting fully reworked by
riot barely anyone plays him his kit
allows you to toy with your enemies and
occasionally pull off some nice outplays
in matchmaking but that doesn't quite
cut it in pro play there's the ultimate
bear chasing him down
so oh what i'll just try to follow up
there he's going to punish him he dips
down again he finds the third mitch
what is this round i want to even close
it man plenty of other agents have
better flashes than euro and when it
comes to making space as an entry
fragger or even just taking map control
on defense there are much more reliable
options for that as well so after
failing to make an impact in the pro
meta it seemed like yoru would remain
stuck as a useless agent that nobody
ever picked but at vct masters reykjavik
2022 one team decided to give yuru a
chance paper rex are arguably one of the
weirdest teams in the global valerian
scene because
they do a lot of stuff that's out of the
ordinary i didn't really want to be like
one of those boring teams that just come
out looking all serious you know i just
wanted to like to like lighten up the
atmosphere
and i mean if you can't be remembered as
like the best team you might as well be
remembered as the funniest right can i
have i have production okay let's see
how fast you can peel this off go it's a
whole process
how does he take doesn't it have a belt
oh he doesn't care about the belt that
ain't going well yeah oh okay oh i love
it
ben kai the team's leader is most famous
for showing up to every international
match in a different wacky costume but
the other thing he's known for is his
love for weird team comps hell this guy
ran phoenix another failure of an agent
on breathe his absolute worst map and
somehow made it work the same goal for
jensen to try to equalize the score to
ensure they have the whole benefit spike
comes down and the fire just scorches
and burns and works in the back there
edward coming through as ben kai does
get one out of the way jensen gonna be
respecting that and he's gonna go down
as well benkai how did you do that
isolating the members and got so much
value out of it by playing the corner
here might be good for one here comes
one that we talked about java i get two
will be three not quite as he
repositions himself right now he's stuck
with it
[Applause]
luckily for benkai he has an amazing
supporting cast of talented players who
he knows will always pop off no matter
how crazy his comps get but for our
purposes the most important one of those
players is forsaken and no not that
forsaken although both players did come
from cs go the forsaken on paper rex is
one of the nastiest duelest players in
valor in today since bank in the
meantime did find izzy's now fancy
forsaken ready and waiting ahead of the
curve long interesting okay drop down
first in no trade nothing it was just
easy
left to rock just
what
what is this for a retake no trades no
timing no spacing forsaken will laugh
that up every day of the week if there
was anybody who could make your work at
the highest level of play
it was forsaken
paper rex traveled to iceland as the
number one seed from apac and as the
number one team they also secured
themselves a group stage buy and since
they were placed directly into the
playoffs they got to hide a lot of their
strats and team comps from the
competition which was good because they
had a trick up their sleeve after they
opened their masters campaign by
defeating drx on map one the series
moved to bind which is where paper rex
decided to bust out forsaken's yoru now
that might have seemed like an insane
pick after all yoru was the worst agent
in the game at the time but if there's
one map where his gimmicks actually work
it's bind just throwing footsteps of the
hookah tp every single round making them
always guess oh is this guy here or not
you basically lock down hookah like you
make that
uh so
hard so scary for the enemy team doing
little stuff like that and having little
one-way flashes
and knowing how to catch people off
guard i think especially on my band they
have like two teleporting two teleport i
think it worked well on in vine because
especially the the your decoy you can
make a lot of gameplay with the fake
decoy like for example
you can do like a fake
decoy to tp
make them like confused throughout apac
stage one forsaken busted out your one
bine a few times to decent success still
the agent had a track record of never
winning at an international lan on any
map no matter who ran him and so despite
all of forsaken's incredible skill drx
dumped yoru right back in the trash can
paper rex found him in
forsaken still just trying to sneak his
way trying to ruin the day of stacks but
he will land the headshot in the end
around that never should have been
macko in trouble he ends up getting
falling for the decoy
shaken
that was huge
i don't think he spotted him i think
marco managed to dodge within the tube
and because of that it's all fallen
apart it seems like the euro game
at that time has been read by the drx so
like my movement
my gameplay and my like my playstyle
it seems like
they read us like a book you know
so
i think we lost because
they just better with the counter
strategy as prx's lower bracket run
began their next opponent the guard made
the smart decision to ban bind but even
without their niche pick paper rex
managed to send na's number one seed
home to earn their first ever
international win and set up a match
against g2 in the next round
and g2 made one fatal error during map
vetoes unlike the guard g2 left bind in
the map pool in fact they picked it
themselves g2 actually had a solid win
rate on bind so the pick made sense but
they weren't prepared for forsaken's
yoru
meadow weeks better this year yeah here
we go again yaru is back in the only
person bala that's played yoru this
whole tournament yeah and in any masters
tournament except all the way back in
reykjavik after dumpstering g2 on split
with jet forsaken pivoted to yoru on
bind and got to work from the very start
forsaken made use of yoru's mind gamey
fake out and gate crash abilities to
keep g2 guessing sometimes he'd used him
to regroup with the rest of his team
though other times he'd managed to get
behind enemy lines and catch his
opponents off guard and once his alt
came online forsaken was able to gather
plenty of info to help paper rex execute
onto the site different nukey to see
space but time is such an issue
the player on the other side catching
him first three to one for paper rex
paper x were constantly able to
capitalize off the space that forsaken
was taking with yoru's utility so even
when he wasn't necessarily getting frags
forsaken was still able to have a huge
impact on the game by setting up his
teammates g2 had no answer to any of it
forsaken was doing something different
almost every round and since yoru isn't
typically picked in pro play jitu had no
idea how to deal with him they seemed to
expect about our play style but i don't
think they knew about peprak strategy or
tactic like the utility combo
so it's easy for us to get the
bomb side and play around with my
teleporter skill and once forsaken
started really hitting heads
g2 were in trouble control sending out
his decoy to seize a bit of space to
distract these players maybe feed them
the information as well you're not going
to attempt the tp okay fakes the tv
that's actually going to cause a bit of
a problem they've got to now be worried
about him already being in the spawn
selling the fake information this is i
mean we're already starting to see the
value from yoru that we did last time
forsaken consistently made perfect use
of his utility to keep his opponents on
their toes not only was he fragging out
but he also forced g2 to waste a lot of
time checking whether his teleports were
real or fake g2 answered back with a few
rounds of their own but it didn't take
long for forsaken to start tricking them
again
and a judge up close on the other side
which means death he chose death not
surprising considering the options and
forsaken has just traded out his own
decoy meadow gets the head shot on the
wrong one that operator now ready to
take them down the shots missed though a
lifeline perhaps and they've caught him
on the way out the flash is perfect
paper x set to pick up an eighth closing
out this half
an incredibly dominant fashion and even
look at that the tp off the alt into
spawn they know that he's not coming
from here
there he is
just comes sprinting through and goes
yeah he's coming out hookah
yep free kill nice and easy eight four
eight
honestly this is a devastating high for
g2 it's their map pick tom
yeah but it's the elimination map so it
could be all over fairly soon they might
be eliminated by a yoru
g2 won the pistol round and converted
the anti-ego but it didn't matter
forsaken was ready to send them home
every time g2 thought they had him
forsaken used yoru's kit to escape and
even when g2 did find themselves
actually face to face with him
they didn't fare much better the decoy
was popped and they shot it i know that
they're coming forsaken with another
kill and bangkai tucked in the corner
how does forsaken get away with that he
was so low and a third is found as well
that's utterly unreasonable forsaken
took full control of the game he was
popping heads left and right and the
one-time g2 actually managed to get the
bomb down he showed them just how good
yoru's alt is for retakes here's the
steps the flash is hell oh meadow gets
away with the first forsaken has to take
him down and he does g2 called the
timeout to try to stop the bleeding and
they managed to pick up the following
round but forsaken made sure it cost
them he kept racking up kills and
europe's so-called number one team
just didn't have an answer
confirming the players are still in here
mine freaks picked up another this is
starting to look like it's done how has
evolved gotten away with that but the
answer is immediate meadow the last man
standings taken down an apac have done
it
[Music]
paper rex did the impossible not only
did they take down g2 to guarantee a top
four finish in reykjavik but they did it
with yoru forsaken dominated the entire
series but vine was to stand out he
finished the map with a server high 29
kills and 371
acs it was one of the greatest
performances valrant has ever seen on
lan and he pulled it off with one of the
game's most hopeless picks which goes to
show that without teams like prx
valorent wouldn't be nearly as
interesting to watch every esport needs
teams like them teams that are willing
to break the meta or even try to reshape
it themselves i felt really happy and
proud
of myself and also my team of course
personally with geru i think
like you have to be like creative and
you have to be brave
with that agent because with the
teleport gameplay it really helped you
to make a play so if you like know how
to use that agent better surely i think
many team will be like tired against
yoru i think forsaken's triumph was the
first time yoru ever won on an
international stage and everyone who is
watching that day will remember forsaken
and paper rex for being the first ones
to prove that in the right hands
any agent can be viable
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this then hit the sub
button and ring the notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock
[Music]
you